avant de devenir un artiste polyforme
doumé a eu un passé industriel pendant
19 ans il était mode leurs mots liste
est évidemment ce passé industriel lui a
sacrément servi quand il est devenu
artiste plasticien alors aujourd'hui le
travail que le bois l'acier le bronze ou
encore le plastique et vous allez le
voir il est toujours fasciné par le
grand donc ça c'est un poste à souder
qui me permet de souder le métal ici une
scie à onglet pour tout ce qui est des
coupes de bois et plastique et aluminium
et une tronçonneuse avec laquelle je
découpe toutes les châssis en métal
c'est un paradoxe chez nous mais son
atelier tout petit c'est pourtant là
qu'il crée ses oeuvres dont la taille
est toujours conséquente
enfer en bois en aluminium un bronze
l'on gagne souple gédoux mais à la base
il ya toujours une émotion
c'est mon premier travaux sur une
émotion négative suite à une friction
canard pas de famille voilà quelque
chose qui m'est l'image qui m'est venue
brutalement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui peuvent pas
l'approcher celle ci je pourrais
peut-être désherber
moins conflictuelle celle-là sur fond de
rupture professionnelle cette fois avec
au passage un sacré clin d'oeil à son
grand père
c'est ce que j'ai ressenti quand j'ai
changé d'activité de vie voilà c'est
le fait de lâcher quelque chose
d'aborder autre chose de découvrir
quelque chose notre façon vive de pensée
de notre ouverture surtout je crois que
c'est notre ouverture mais la liberté
pour doom et n'aurait aucun sens s'il
n'y avait pas le partage
donc sur la partie inférieure je pense
qu'on mettra des morceaux de capot
à l'image de ce qu'il avait fait avec
des australiens de bitche porte il a
donné envie à une poignée de faire tes
vient de participer à son drôle de
vaisseau
pas des artistes mais des habitants
lambda qui se sont pris au jeu tout le
monde a voulu ce matin au cintrage à la
soudure je pense est un petit peu des
parcs chacun ferait là des choses là où
il se sent le plus à l'aise finalement
tout le monde a touché à tout c'était
assez assez marrant et enrichissant
une voix grave des textos raffiné et un
univers joyeusement mélancolique
bertrand belin fait escale au bouillon
une excellente programmation du festival
de travers
c'est une pièce manquante qui cherche à
créer le trouble chez le spectateur
la chorégraphe castelroussine cécile
loyer s'appuie cette fois sur la tempête
de shakespeare peut-être pour nous
déconcerter un peu plus
on savait que les saxophonistes était un
peu timbré balle de saxe revient avec
shakespeare et mendelssohn parce que la
musique classique ça n'est pas forcément
ennuis
d'accord c'est en anglais mais ce n'est
pas une raison pour ne pas y elle
se tait ball petit bijou de marionnettes
décapant et drôle et puis pour les nuls
il y aura les surtitrage
et pour finir car me village trois ans
d'existence donne carte blanche à jo âme
ambiance à la edward hopper entre nudité
et désirs charnels un hommage plus
qu'appuyé à 4 carmen
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui prochain
agenda vendredi mais meurent en
attendant n'oubliez pas de sortir est
très bon et ken